hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to breaking the bank this is
the last game in the series well
actually it's the first game in the
series of stick figure games where
you're breaking into and/or stealing
other stuff I couldn't have played it in
a more wrong order because I played the
third one stealing the diamond the
second one doing breaking out of jail
whatever it was called and then the
third one infiltrating a fourth one in
for leading the rails to the airship and
this is the first one breaking the bank
it is probably the shortest one but this
is the one that the guy made first and
in the story line which is weird because
I know practically everything that's
going to happen and I know the disguise
is a correct option because of the
Phoenix right segment that was in the
second game ever and was another way
that I could have gotten out I'm going
to get stuck in the wall that would
actually be unbelievably horrible he he
just looks sad though like oh god not
again but oddly it's the first time that
it's ever happened to me laser drill any
physical abnormality is going to be
having here oh no that's right it's
gonna fall on me I can already call that
it's gonna fall right up alright how do
I know these amazing things Oh
why would you put rockets in with your
bunch of explosives Oh No oh very smart
go right towards the explosives that's
definitely gonna that's like my worst
fear if there was ever a point where
explosives weren't going to go off right
away Legend of Zelda much but if they
weren't gonna go off right away that
would be my worst fear just having them
be there and you have to go next to them
and as soon as you getting
duck-duck-goose
I don't know god it's like it's it's so
weird did I get hit by a train before I
can't remember if it was a point in
another game where I got hit by a train
because oddly enough there's only so
many ways that the stick figure could
die in these games so possibly that's
got two big things that overlap but it's
even weirder because I knew that the
teleporter wasn't gonna work because it
was an inside joke in like this third or
second one saying it didn't work out
that's so sad
for you why okay this guy's this guy got
framed for this guy's crime cuz he's a
dick how did he manage to do that at all
did like people in the comments of
Newgrounds say that like weird stuff
happening yeah just to be safe
this odd human shaped bag filled with
not what feels like money should go into
the guard vault blam now what okay
you're locked in a vault how did you
plan to go already are in there what do
you want for me oh no not the end oh no
that's it oh my god every other game
have like ten thousand varieties of
options and that's the end of it oh no I
knew it was gonna be sure but if I knew
it was gonna be that short I would've
just played it in the last one that I
did oh man I feel so bad ah what else
could we possibly do for the rest of its
episode I know I feel like I cheated you
I feel like I robbed you of what you
deserved
I feel like I didn't give you the
entertainment that you craved we could
look up adorable pictures of kittens or
something I don't know let's see
painting for you guys probably oh that's
the same one but reversed he gave
I know it's so cute Joe video Pabu it
did me don't know what else to do for
this episode I guess that's the end of
it hey I guess that's all there is to it
so just thank you all so much for
watching and thank you for enjoying this
series of games I never expected you
guys to love it as much as you did but
I'm grateful anyway so it is thank you
guys so much for watching check out the
other videos that I've done about this
series in the description below you've
probably already seen them already
that's the end for this one so thank you
again everybody for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
so Manny
Oh